scientists are developing a replacement
for rubber here at the University of
Minnesota's Center for Sustainable
polymers so we want to look for rubbery
materials things that are stretchy that
are elastic that can be extended and
they snap right back
this process starts with starch from
corn chemists can synthesize the polymer
in the lab dry it and then mold it once
we form some of the rubbers that we use
today
we can't reprocess them they can just be
ground up and make the playground rubber
material but this you can melt and
reprocess and reuse it and it's
compostable that's what we strive for
right because we don't want to have our
ocean filled with classics so why aren't
materials like this in all of our shoes
already so I oftentimes joke that my lab
has produced a lot of materials that
have interesting and exciting properties
but nobody really cares about them
that's because the bio plastics in this
lab are still relatively expensive to
produce especially now with oil prices
so low the unfortunate reality is that
consumers like you will not pay a
premium for bio renewability or
degradability or not much of a premium
an ideal bioplastic would not only look
and perform as well as petroleum-based
plastics it would be just as cheap and
easy to produce it probably won't look
any different I'll still grab the bag to
put my fruit in at the grocery store
except it'll be from bio-based
feedstocks and except when I throw it
away it'll have a facile route to
decomposition to give environmentally
innocuous byproducts
if this lab succeeds a better world
might look a lot like the one we already
live in